this presentation is called python as a
hackable language for interactive data
science and my name is Stephen and I'm
very excited to be here thanks to all of
the num Focus
hosts uh for organizing this event uh
it's really a
privilege um so with that let's go ahead
and get
started so just a little bit about me um
I'm an engineer at data bricks based in
the Seattle area I don't know if uh my
camera is still visible though if it is
you might see some palm trees in the
background that's because right now I'm
in the beautiful island of kawaii uh on
vacation so that's a great benefit of a
global conference you can do it from
anywhere um and if you hear a rooster in
the background you know don't worry it's
just a rooster no nothing too crazy is
going
on
um one of my big passions is is
computational notebook technology uh
you'll probably see a lot more of that
as we go through this
presentation and uh when I'm not working
on open source projects I uh enjoy
helping my wife out in our garden and
unfortunately uh our cat has recently
figured out how to escape from the
garden it's normally enclosed but uh you
know when there's a will there's a way
so we have to figure out how to cat
proof it once we get
back so let's talk a little bit about uh
what who this presentation is for so
there's really two groups of folks uh
and those are tool users so people who
use Python to do some kind of data
analysis as well as people who want to
implements tools for data analysis using
Python and I hope that if you're in the
latter category uh you might come away
from this presentation with some ideas
maybe some crazy ones perhaps uh for
ways we can improve people doing uh the
lives of folks doing interactive data
analysis uh the only knowledge however
that I'm going to assume is a very basic
knowledge of uh python or
Jupiter so with that uh let's talk a
little bit about why is python so good
for data science like why has it kind of
I I mean there's definitely uh other
Alternatives you know but generally
speaking python has really dominated the
data science scene and I think um and
this is just my opinion but I think it
comes down to two answers uh the first
is of course the ecosystem of data
adjacent libraries there's so many
different libraries to do almost
anything you could possibly want and
secondly which I think is a little more
subtle is that it has really great
tooling for interactive programming so
data analysis uh data analysis in
particular is uh something that really
benefits from interactivity
because a lot of times when you're
writing a program to do some data
analysis you don't necessarily know what
is the code that you want to write until
after uh you see some preliminary
results so being able to iterate kind of
in that interactive fashion is why tools
like IPython and Jupiter and other tools
like spider vs code notebooks and you
may have seen Maro which is like the new
hotness have uh just been so useful for
that and so in this presentation I'm
going to focus on Jupiter in particular
and ways we can kind of augment Jupiter
to uh do some kind of uh outside the
box uh optimizations for your data
analysis
workflow so one underappreciated aspect
of python towards this end is its
extensibility so let me just give the
simplest possible example of one way in
which
uh python is kind of extensible and how
that has kind of benefited users of
interactive tools like Jupiter the
simplest example I think is the top
level of weight in IPython so here we
have you know an async function and
normally you can't call this function
directly but here because we're in
Jupiter um I can actually run this like
so uh with the top level of weight um
and this normally isn't allowed normally
you're not allowed to call a weight
outside of an async function but Jupiter
has uh or IPython actually has a
Transformer an a Transformer which
essentially rewrites uh the
above uh call into something that's a
lot less convenient um but you know more
correct from a pythonic standpoint where
it's getting in an event Loop and
running the async function until it's
complete definitely a lot less
convenient
though
um the um so let's talk a little bit
about abstract syntax tree
Transformations so the top level of
weight is one example of an A
transformation and it turns out that
python exposes an API for these as
Transformers via as
visitors so uh what are some of the
interactive features we can enable if we
leverage these to their full extent like
if we just take this to its logical
conclusion what can we do so let's take
a look at some
examples and I'll just say uh as we're
going through this presentation all of
these examples leverage an
instrumentation Library called
Piccolo
um and if you'd like to follow along
yourself uh they run within a special
current uh alternative to the uh IPI
kernel called ipy flow and ipy flow
exposes a hook to uh kind of hook into
Piccolo
functionality and this presentation you
probably notice is just a notebook so if
you would like to actually follow along
with these examples yourself you can
download it at the link github.com
flow datag Global
2023 and you know you can always come
back later after the presentation as
well if you want to try it out this is
going
anywhere so let's look at our first
example called optional chaining so this
is inspired from a uh recent flavors of
JavaScript which actually have this
great Syntax for what's called optional
chaining or maybe monads where you can
say hey if I don't know whether some
variable is null or not I can prefix it
with a question mark before I do a DOT
and and then um that way even if it's
null we can kind of co oress uh
subsequent things into a null value
without you know a bunch of IFL
statements to check everything so we can
actually add this to python it turns out
um so let's see how so first I'm just
going to run this snippet here which uh
basically registers the instrumentation
or a transformation that enables this
functionality
h
then I will go ahead and run something
we're just going to get you know a
simple class that kind of has an
attribute uh that we can you know one
that has a value and one that will be
null which will be important
later so let's go ahead and see how this
works of course I can do F now I can do
Fu question mark. Fu and of course this
evaluates to
42 um but I can also you know uh
evaluate the null attribute and I can
try to uh call get an attribute on the
null attribute uh but when I prefix it
with this question mark we can see that
it kind of coalesces to none and this
works for even more complicated uh
chains of
attributes um where I can coales them
into none with this kind of question
mark
syntax Okay
so you know this hopefully this wets
your appetite a little bit with kind of
some of the ways we can actually extend
python to make it maybe more convenient
for certain use cases uh but we're just
getting started so let's go on to the
next example and this is one of my
favorite examples um for this example
we're actually going to make all
assignment statements to simple
variables non-blocking so that it
appears as if they run
instantaneously
um
so that's the idea we're going to try
and make all variable assignment appear
instantaneous uh and then we'll only
block execution if a variable is used in
a load context so if a variable we
assigns to uh is used in a load context
that's when we'll actually start
blocking and waiting for the evaluation
to
finish um that is we can actually get
away with a also making it appear
instantaneous if the load context is
itself part of a variable assignment so
this probably looked a little bit
abstract let's see what this looks like
in practice so I'm going to do the same
thing before where I register the
instrumentation to uh make this example
work so I'll just go ahead and run this
code snippet
here okay and for this particular
example we're going to simulate some
expensive computation with this function
expensive which sleeps for 3 seconds uh
before it Returns the value that was
passed to
it okay so let's go ahead and run this
code stimp it where we assign X we we
assign expensive of one to X and as you
can see it appears to have run
instantaneously and that's because of
our instrumentation we ran and now let's
go ahead and run this and assign X+ 10
to Y this also appears to run
instantaneous because we even though we
used X in a load context we were
assigning we were doing just another
simple variable assignment so we can
keep track of all of the dependencies
and figure out when it's okay to uh
avoid
blocking let's go ahead and make another
expensive call here this again appears
to be
instantaneous and I think I've probably
been talking for about 3 seconds if you
consider that to be think time it
appears as if this entire chain has been
instantaneous so uh if I actually run
this quickly you can see it block so
I'll go ahead and run maybe
whoops let's try getting back here maybe
try running from here I'll go ahead and
run this and then run this and then run
this and you can see this time it
actually blocked because I ran it
quickly enough that um kind of my think
time was no longer leveraged because
there wasn't
uh enough time to wait for the execution
to finish in the background but you can
imagine if you're doing something with
uh really large data frames and you kind
of know what computation you want to do
and you want to start running it without
uh waiting for uh intermediate results
to complete you can imagine that this
might be a very uh convenient bit of
functionality to have access
to
um
okay but this is all Child's Play
compared to the big one which is
reactive
execution so let's talk about reactive
execution so you may have heard of the
state problem or out of order execution
it's a very well documented problem in
notebooks there's a great presentation
uh from Jupiter con 2018 I think by Joel
Gru called I don't like not books which
talks about this issue uh in a lot of
detail it's amazing presentation highly
recommend you check it out if you
haven't seen it before I don't like
notebooks Joel Cru Jupiter Kong
2018 um and well the reason for this is
that uh the reason for some of these
problems with notebooks is that you can
kind of run things out of order and it
gets really hard to keep track of the
state of the notebook because you have
to think about it in your head the whole
time so one one partial solution to this
problem is to reactively rerun dependent
cells uh whenever something changes so
let's take a look at what that looks
like in practice so once again I'm going
to get rid of the previous
instrumentation and register some new
instrumentation that permits this
reactive execution let's go ahead and do
that and let's do some simple code here
xals
Z could do yal x + one
and just to like spice it up a bit we'll
throw a print statement in there
something that doesn't have any
dependencies on the previous
things and then we'll just print
y
so um with the iy flow kernel which is
what this is running on uh the way this
works is when I have a particular cell
selected anything that has a DOT next to
it has a data flow relationship with the
selected cell so in this case y has a
data flow relationship with this cell y
= x +1 as well as this cell xal 0 and in
particular you may have notice some of
these dots are purple this dot is orange
what does that mean well anything with
an orange dot will also execute when the
selected cell executes so for example if
I come up here and select X
whoops if I come up here and select x
equals 0 you can see uh cells 23 24 and
26 all have orange dots
I select yal x +1 cell 24 and 26 have
orange dots let's actually try running
something in here so I'll change this to
xal 42 run this and you can see indeed
all of the orange cells
reran I could come here change this to
something else and once
again uh the things that had orange dots
next to them reran and you uh the
important thing here is of course the
thing that wasn't related to these cells
at all this print statement was totally
skipped so if this is like some
expensive computation that's not
necessary it'll totally get skipped um
and it won't have in or if it has side
effects you know um it'll also get
skipped so so this is the basic idea of
reactive
execution uh basically automatically
refresh anything that has maybe gotten
out of sync uh so that the kind of top
to bottom visual presentation of the
notebook uh is exactly in sync with the
state of the notebook kind of what you
see is what you
get and um I'll also note that reactive
execution is great for interactive
widgets so let's take a look at what uh
how we can use reactive execution with
interactive widgets so here I have a
cell I'm just getting uh kind of some
x's along an
x-axis and then here's a cell to create
a slider we'll see how we use this later
on uh this will be our widget that we're
going to kind of use to interact with
our plot here's our plot and you can see
what we're essentially doing is we're
plotting cosine uh and the period it is
kind of set by our slider value so the
higher that we put our slider value the
uh kind of the higher the frequency of
this plot and so here's the slider and
with reactive execution I can toggle
this and you can see I just increased
the frequency of the plot I can increase
it even more if I want I can move it
back down again and so this is kind of
like a great educational tool uh being
able to change sliders and have actually
different cells uh depend on the slider
value uh and you you know this will work
for other kinds of widgets as well but
sliders are
probably um the best example to to
illustrate uh how much how useful
interact reactivity can
be
so should probably move on with the
presentation and not get too distracted
uh but it really is fun to play around
with so you might be wondering though
why do we actually need Transformations
or instrumentation to enable reactivity
like couldn't we just kind of statically
analyze the code to figure out when
something needs to rerun and for easy
cases it's true that uh static analysis
does suffice um but uh in general once
you get to some of the corner cases it
gets really really difficult to figure
out what actually
changed uh in order to reactively rerun
something so let's look at an example of
this so let's look at one of the harder
cases so here I have you know I'm just
setting some variables in this cell here
so let's run
that and
then um I'll go ahead and reference the
first value X as well as the second
value
y now let's take a look at this second
cell here what do we think happens when
I run
this well one of two things is going to
happen either we're going to increment X
or we're going to increment y
and we don't actually know which one is
going to increment until we run this so
when you think about it it's actually
impossible to figure out what is the
correct reactive execution for this
particular example if we don't have some
kind of instrumentation that actually
allows us to observe the values as they
change and just to show you that this
works I'll go ahead and run this and in
this case it looks like um y was the
thing that got incremented because you
can see uh that that's the one that
reran down
here um you so you might say okay
well this is kind of a contrived example
um but when you think about it anything
that needs some kind of runtime
introspection really needs these kinds
of uh as Transformations or
instrumentation in order to figure out
uh what actually changed so let's look
at another example uh this is this
example uh uses what's called
memorization so what we're going to do
is we're going to try and Skip code that
would give the same result if we've
already seen it before so once again
let's go ahead with our setup going to
import
time and here we're going to simulate
another slow method in a class called Fu
um basically it's just going to return
some constant but it's going to sleep
for two seconds before doing
that
okay so now we're going to get an
instance of Fu shoved into a dictionary
so we'll go ahead and run
that and down here we'll go ahead and uh
run this particular uh cell which will
actually call our slow method and then
show the
result okay so so far so
good now if I rerun this top cell here
uh you can see it's the exact same code
so theoretically we shouldn't have to uh
actually reexecute our slow stuff we can
just get the memorized version and it'll
be fast and that's exactly what happens
when I do that uh and this is only
possible because we can actually see the
code and we can see the runtime values
and tell that they haven't changed if
they do change so let's go ahead and
change this to something
else this time you can see that it
actually is slow again it took some
time uh but if I change it back to
something that i' seen
before it's
fast and if I change this back to
something that I've seen
before fast
again
and let's change to something it hasn't
seen it's slow taking a couple of
seconds and if I change it back to
something that it
seen fast again so in order for this to
work you really have to know what's
executed previously you have to know uh
if the runtime values match up with
something that you've seen before uh and
so this is another case where it's
really beneficial to have
instrumentation so you can actually see
what
changed so you might be wondering how
does all of this work
well uh I mentioned we're using
Transformers but it's actually really
hard to get all of these examples to
work with traditional Transformers uh
because usually we need to register a
bunch of different ones um and they tend
to kind of conflict with each other they
don't compose very well uh so to give
you an example of what I'm talking about
let say I want to you know rewrite all
binary operations with a plus uh to add
a new binary operation well if I'm doing
this multiple times uh it's going to
kind of explode and cause um and they'll
they'll conflict with each other so to
combat this these examples all use a
library called Piccolo and what Piccolo
allows you to do is it allows you to
have composable as Transformations so I
can register multiple Transformers in a
way that they won't actually kind of
conflict with each other so let's just
take a quick example so this particular
Transformer um what is it doing well
when we see the a uh the right side of a
binary operation it's just going to
increment
it so if I actually register the uh the
instrumentation for that and then I Run
2 plus two you can see we get
five
um now what if I want to register
another Transformer that increments the
right binary operation by two well if I
were using a traditional as
Transformer uh you know this 2 plus two
would have gotten Rewritten to 2 plus 2+
1 and then both of these 2 plus 2 as
well as 2+ 1 would have gotten Rewritten
to uh be incremented by two and so it
would actually end up incrementing this
by four if I if I go ahead and register
this if I were using a traditional a
Transformer but with Piccolo they
compose so I can go ahead and run this
and this time I'll get I think seven
right and 2+ 2 + 1 plus
two um I'll get seven instead of nine
because these will compose
nicely uh and don't kind of conflict
with each
other so uh in conclusion python is
actually surprisingly
hackable uh and its hackability and
enables all kinds of really interesting
interactive use
cases and if you'd like to play around
with some of these examples yourself you
can go to the GitHub repo ipy flowy
datag Global
2023 uh and or you can check out the uh
examples in the piccolo repository
directly and that's at github.com smacky
Piccolo um so with that thank you very
much for your attention and I think I
have a few minutes left to open it to
questions if there are any really
appreciate your
attention and I was not able to see
anything at all uh while presenting so
my apologies if there were questions